now there were some of the angriest
scenes that I've ever seen in Parliament
this week as MPs argued about the
language used in political debate and
shared stories of some of the abuse that
they've received and absolute doesn't
you think
would anyone want to be an MP well some
of these women do we're joined now by
Nicola Lowery the chair of Dunford
conservative Association
Alyssia Ken's a conservative activist
former candidate and Laura Evans who is
the Conservative candidate for world
West thank you very much for being on
the program nice and early on I think we
have to go to that first question why
would anyone want to be an MP I think
people feel really impassioned
particularly at this pivotal time to
stand up for their community firstly to
ensure that we do enact the referendum
result of 2016 to ensure that we do
uphold democracy I know a lot of women
locally and within the party generally
speaking that want to ensure that we do
stand up for conservative values for
aspirations so I think it's really
important whilst it is a very critical
in criminal time that we do ensure that
we stand up for those values so I can
understand why people have concerns but
it creates important that we do
represent our views in Parliament's I
mean is it a worry day when you look at
some of these stories at MPs have shared
and it is a piece of all sides of the
house all sides that are brexit debate
is it something that concerns you I
think it's difficult because I imagine
all three of us are faced at different
times in the last election I was spat
out I was chased down the street I
received abuse but I think it's quite
difficult one because I think when you
want to step forward for public life
you're doing it because you genuinely
believe you can make a difference and
that it matters and actually there are
people in other careers that get this as
well so when I worked in HS I received
death threats me and my team because we
were trying to improve services and
people didn't like the way we were
proposing to do it isn't the NHS would
be if you could have choose any
profession where you'd be safe from that
kind of thing do you think that there is
a perhaps a incumbency on politicians to
try and moderate their language when
feelings clearly are running very high
the minute I think that the thing that I
came into the whole role because I have
a small business so I'm a business
champion and I felt that actually small
businesses were hardly being listened to
within govern
and it's very different when you walk
and you've been in the NHS you've just
said so when you walk to walk you can
actually talk to talk you know how hard
it is so on that front that's probably
why I came into on the second front this
has been going a long time social media
plays a great part because you see it
more we have cameras watching all day
long but even in when I was a counselor
I'd sit there and I was you know comment
to a Mon you shame on you from local
counters sitting next to me who were in
the opposition we saw unfortunately with
Esther Lynch I'm not going to use the
word vile word unnecessary from the
opposition you know a plague in all our
houses none of us are perfect
should we temperate absolutely can we do
better of course we can and hopefully we
will but people are very upset and they
want to get the vote done they voted for
something and they want it delivered
passions are high this is very very
important do you agree with that then
you can see we're nodding along like
you're talking about and we do I think
MPs needs to be mindful that the world
is watching so I would encourage members
to consider moderating their language
it's a very emotive topic we're looking
at the future of our country the role of
the judiciary we're looking at how we
depart from the EU so they're very
emotive subject about forests Johnson's
violent number ten I would defend his
position on the surrender acts because
we are essentially surrendering our
position to Brussels so I can understand
why he is using that sort of language
but I would encourage the opposition
benches to consider some of the language
they are using it's important that we do
have respectful debates you can do that
by putting straight talking language we
shouldn't confuse the two because I do
appreciate the general public is feeling
very frustrated and MPs are representing
their constituents so we shouldn't
stifle debate but I think we can do it
in a more constructive and respectful
manner actually language that is violent
by Nature
yes so talk about knifing people on the
front talking about lynching people talk
about civil disobedience which we seen
David Lammy talk about the last few days
I do think and anonymous conservative
business as well I should say it's not
all this is one of challenges why I
think the innominate anonymity needs to
almost end if people want to use on
offensive language inappropriate
language they need to own up to it
because if they're being anonymous it's
because they know that language isn't
okay so ultimately we do we all need to
have more respect we do around Therese
the name I suppose as well wasn't that
often a case of filibustering because
actually I haven't got much to say so
you know calling the word surrender
surrender
inappropriate okay well what should we
give our packages that we want to call
it what do you want to call it I mean
the fact is that it's it isn't really
the case I mean it was hardly a battle
plan with what they've delivered the way
to to go forward the pen act it has made
it so difficult that people are
frustrated and we are at the brunt of
that of course I'm keen to talk a bit
about some of the points that David Galt
just raised in the interview before we
know he is clearly someone who is
concerned about the direction of the
Conservative Party he doesn't think that
it's in an election winning position
unless it go to the center ground he's
obviously worried about some of those
seats you know in the south and do you
think he's got a point I recognized some
of the aspects that he raises but
equally I think the Conservative Party
is very United certainly since we've had
a new prime minister we've really
focused our determination on getting a
deal not really almost Minister of 21
being kicked out potentially but the
Prime Minister was coming back next week
we understand with more details on the
turnit of arrangement will hopefully
negate the need for the backstop so I do
feel as though the party is very united
in our commitment to upholding the
referendum vote committed in our
aspirations for the Conservative Party
and our domestic agenda which we want to
deliver which is why the Prime Minister
is really clearly stood on that he wants
a general election so we can legislate
and get out through Parliament to ensure
that we do deliver in the national
interest do you think that the
Conservative Party needs to win from the
centre so I think I have a real issue
with this a concert that we're kicking
out the moderates it just isn't true and
I think it is unfortunately an untrue
and untruth what's happened is that a
group of MPs who might have broken away
for the first time ever voted to give
power to the Opposition so the
opposition could instruct the government
what it can I can't do that is something
we cannot have an unfortunate discipline
did fall apart under the last under
trees of May and so we do need to bring
back discipline but it's not kicking out
the moderates and David Gore could be
here at conference he's speaking
contrast that to Luciana Berger who went
to her own conference when she was a
Labour Party member well she decided to
she chose to but I think it's the
treatment that's different so David Koch
will come here the next few days and
there might be people that want to
debate the panel so she chose to resign
because I mean at Machine she would also
feel that she was effectively forced out
she wasn't agreed on that point but that
is you know no I take the point yeah you
know I think we have to be careful that
that that running vain that we've seen
see if we are very polite up we're not
using the word anti-semitism we're not
going down these roads because
conservative by name in nature but where
we are today the reason that it's so hot
is because people want this Rex it's
very quick folks were out of time but
I'm interested in your experience in the
seat that you're in obviously you know
quite a labor leaning like vote you have
to kind of really really try and win
voters over to the concept as I'd
imagine if you're going to win when
that's a beautiful seat do you what
where does the Conservative Party need
to be if it's gonna win seats like the
one you're fighting it is it is it a
risk that you are as some words they're
going too far down the brexit route too
far down the Nigel Farage route do you
need to come back down just to remain
what's holding up the vote where do you
think the concept of party needs to be I
think it's it should be where it is at
the moment so we we cannot have private
schools altered or change in any way
shape or form they are a great resources
I believe in leveling up I believe we've
had Matt Hancock on about Hospital talk
what we're selling go back to the
streets tell people what we're
delivering that's what they want to hear
in my particular area its potholes
it's about being tidy it's about small
businesses it's those sort of things it
hasn't changed
but if you take away faith schools
grammar schools academies private
schools good grief I mean it's just
unacceptable
and that's where we are thank you very
much for coming on and showing or giving
your opinions